so
hey everyone and welcome to another tech
related video what's up guys and uh
today i'm just going to go over with you
um what exactly apple has done yesterday
they made a big release a lot of big
things happened yesterday in the world
of tech so i'm just going to go over
with you i'll probably maximize this
um
in a video series a step of them and
i'll put them together in a playlist so
i'm going to have a bunch of videos
about what apple has done
so there's been a whole desktop refresh
basically so this is going to be video
one about
i'm going to try to cover the mac minis
today so to discover this basically go
to apple.com
and go to the mac tab apple.com mac
and we're just going to go over to the
left and find here we go about halfway
over and find the mac mini just click on
it
so the first thing you're going to
notice is it says faster and i'll get to
that then it says greener and still mini
now we know it's still mini okay
but when they say faster the first thing
to talk about is five times faster
nvidia graphics performance and also a
processing improvement so when they say
faster
they're using the new nvgforce 9400m
graphics processor bringing you
supposedly up to five times faster
graphics performance
as you can see on the screen here
and you can also view the performance
chair i'll just click on here so you
guys can see there you go previous
baseline mac mini and the new mac mini
seven times better and you can use the
apple cinema displays which is really
really sweet so it says the 2.2
gigahertz model compared to the previous
2.0 gigahertz model so it'll probably be
more like here if you're going with the
baseline
baseline mac mini that's new
so that's the first part when they say
faster number two is that they say up to
four gigabytes of memory and we all know
apple likes to put in that ddr3 memory i
don't know if they're doing this with
the mac mini quite yet
but
that is very good four gigs of memory
again it's a desktop so it should have
all the baseline features that a mac
that a desktop does have and it's the
mac mini so we saw that we've all seen
that video of the first um the guys
spinning around the new mac mini several
days before they release it here on
apple.com but you can see as i'm showing
you guys here i'll probably highlight it
there are five usb ports on the back and
we can go around and see the power
button we see the kensington lot audio
in audio out mini dvi firewire 800. i do
believe i have firewire on my
laptops as well
mini displayport and gigabit gigabit
ethernet so that's a pretty basic layout
five usb ports is very good and i give a
decent amount of expandability again
it's a baseline mac so you're not going
to get an amazing specs or anything but
so bring your own keyboard display and
mouse they all they're also expanding
what you can use with the mac mini it's
it's basically
a laptop well i don't want to say that
it's it's got the specs of a laptop
but
it's just a small desktop basically this
is the least expensive mac mini and i'll
go uh go over to the price for you at
the top of their website if you go to
buy now we'll see there's more than one
model actually there's the baseline 2.0
gigahertz with 120 gigabyte hard drive
okay that's going to use the 9400m
graphics already and it has a 2.0
gigahertz intel core 2 duo processor
and you'll get only one gig of ram with
this model but again it's baseline it's
only 600
so um
i mean they're okay specs this is for
someone who's just doing again word
processing they want a simple baseline
mac os 10 leopard you know they're not
going to do that video editing or
anything on the mac mini on the baseline
mac mini so that's what you're going to
get it's not that hard
the second one is the
the new uh faster one the intel core 2
duo the 2.0 gigahertz with a 320
gigabyte hard drive which is slightly
larger
actually it's that's a decent sized hard
drive for a desktop it's not you know
it's not again it's not an imac it's not
a mac pro it's a mac mini and this one's
800 because you're also getting two
gigabytes of ram
and if we do select it you'll see
there's a number of customization
features where you can actually go even
more in depth say i want to get the 2.26
gigahertz processor that's 150 add-on
you can get four gigs of ram like i
showed you also i said it works with the
apple cinema displays you can get one
here for nine hundred dollars of course
i i'm not going to recommend that quite
yet
um of course the apple keyboard mouse i
will go nine i'll go over that in a
later video but that's basically it so
the new mac mini starts at six hundred
dollars if you're looking into it
and
yeah that's basically it so again if you
guys have any questions about the new
line if you have any questions about the
new line of mac minis just subscribe and
send me a message and i might do a video
on it i'll answer your question as much
as i can but again there's a new mac
mini there's a new imac there's a new
mac pro there's iphone 9 i got a lot of
videos to do so guys stay with me here
and hope you like this video so thanks
for watching and subscribe and there
will be plenty more tutorials to come
thanks for watching this one peace